john
um
first off the two responses given so far
covered i think the most important
things or already um
gordon talked about the the need for
an underlying passion and enjoyment if
you don't have that you're not going to
have the longevity that is required in
order to build
skills which is ultimately everything's
going to come down to your ability to
build skills you've got to have some
kind of underlying passion and enjoyment
which will keep you in the game long
enough
to build world championship skills it's
going to take a minimum of five years
and quite possibly considerably longer
than that
um
george talked about the idea of
community you're not going to make it by
yourself so you've got to be able to
build people around you and and build a
trusted environment
around you to develop those skills
what i would add to the the excellent
points that both already raised
alludes to what i said at the start of
this podcast
you've got to be able to identify
some kind of undervalued
elements in whatever industry you're in
and show the world what their true value
is
in addition
you can't go through life
doing the same things as everybody else
and expecting to get different results
this is straightforwardly irrational and
worse it's even arrogant it's
essentially the statement that i'm going
to do the same thing as everyone else
but i believe i'm different
and so they'll work for me
but they didn't work for everyone else
that's like saying no i'm special
no you're not special we're all pretty
much the same
and
in order to be special you're going to
have to exhibit skills that other people
simply don't have
thirdly i would say if you want to
become something truly impressive in
life
you've got to be able to focus on one or
two things
that you do better than anyone else in
your industry
you can't learn everything but you can
be one or two skills and the more
innovative those skills are the better
and you can truly excel at them for
example at the peak of his career
no one in the world was better than
george st pierre at integrating striking
and takedowns
no one in the world was better at
integrating grappling and striking on
the ground
he had two things that he could
confidently say he was the best in the
world at was he the best at every mma
skill nope
but he was
absolutely the best at those two skills
and those two skills were skills which
he used throughout his career to win
the vast majority of his matches
gordon ryan at the onset of his career
could confidently say there's no one in
the world better than me at leglocks
he could also say there's no one better
in the world at me at late stage defense
to submission holds across the board
as he went through his career he started
adding more and more elements it's
gotten to an extraordinary degree now
where you could absolutely say he's the
best at guard passing the best of guard
retention and
the less this keeps going on and that
goes back to what
um
gordon said earlier about keeping things
interesting over time because we're
always introducing new skill sets the
day you start saying
i'm satisfied with my skill set is the
day you get bored
and bored boredom to an athlete is a
precursor to
death by boredom
as long as you're still growing in those
directions you'll stay in the game
for for very long periods of time so the
main thing i would add to these uh
statements by gordon and george is this
idea of
finding something which is currently
undervalued and showing the world what
its true value is
understanding
that you can't just use the same
training methodologies as everyone else
and somehow expect to be different from
everyone else you've got to
almost every great rise in human
civilization whether it be groups of
people or individuals requires some kind
of innovation you've got to look for
that new angle okay george st pierre
found it with shoot boxing early on in
his career
gordon ryan found it with leglocks early
on in his career and they branched out
from that
from that angle
add to this the idea that you want to
become the absolute best in the world in
your industry and one or two things that
make a difference
find out what they are and focus on
those things and you'll go far